[Musique]
aucun déjà un peu française il valait à
15 cents mètres d'altitude conduit dans
cette cuvette gigantesque au milieu de
laquelle la famille que l'on gros vie
six mois par an ce chalet comme on dit
dans les montagnes abrite huit personnes
le père la mère et six enfants
monsieur que longo va vendre au marché
les produits de la ferme
la route est longue il faut être à la
ville à 7h30 les chemins de montagne
sont difficiles mais papillon le cheval
connaît le parcours il a ses habitudes
cultivateur ils ont pour capitale vingt
vaches quelques chèvres qui leur donne
le les vases de leur production ils sont
fromagers notre propos c'est de vous
parler de michel la fille aînée
à ce titre elle a des droits mais
surtout des devoirs aujourd'hui jeudi
jour de repos pour les frères et soeurs
michel est sa maman il ya en france une
variété infinie de fromage un pour
chaque jour paraît-il les colons vont
fabriquer reblochon c'est une spécialité
d'autre à voir
en voici la recette
le lait est passé dans un tamis de fer
blanc puis à jc jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
qualifié l'opération demande environ une
demi-heure au préalable madame que longo
a versé un ferment dans l'est
[Musique]
sous la surveillance de maurice les deux
petites filles apprennent déjà la
fabrication du reblochon
[Musique]
e
le moment est venu de séparer le petit
lait
[Musique]
ce vieux moulin buret aux armes de la
famille
ensuite le nez cahier est réparti dans
des moules à reblochon pressés à la main
et recouvert d'un tube un poids de 1 kg
appuyé sur le couvercle de bois
[Musique]
dix minutes plus tard on retourne le
fromage et l'opération recommencera deux
fois dessus puis le tulle et enlevé six
ans plus tard le fromage du matin et ça
les placer sur des clés les fromages
sèche pendant six jours
ensuite ils seront lavés
dernière opération après ces charges les
rues blachon sont entreposés dans la
cave où il devait mourir pendant 15
jours ou trois semaines en fonction de
l'humidité et de narcisse les vaches
aussi ont leurs jours de fête ces jours
là ces grosses cloches d'apparat sont
accrochés à leur cou mais aujourd'hui
jour comme les autres
elles doivent retourner au près
en été la production journalière est de
95 fromage en octobre vous l'avez vu ses
vins rouges ont qui viennent d'être
stockés dans la cave du chalet les
savoyards ont une vie difficile
le travail est permanent les vaches ont
besoin de soins constants
il faut les nourrir prévoir l'hiver
rigoureux et descendre dans la vallée
avant les premières neiges
michel ne pense pas tous là elle prend
un repos bien gagner en compagnie de son
ami fidèle basco
[Musique]